okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about linear combination so what is the
linear combination how do you write a
linear combination this is something
that's important to know for the s80
they have a couple questions like this
I'm on the test so basically what a
linear combination is it's an equation
of a line that is written in standard
form such as this ax plus B y equals C
so we'll look at an example we'll go
through it and you'll have a better
understanding so if an adult ticket
costs six dollars and a child ticket
costs four dollars write an equation to
show the number of adult and children's
tickets that can be purchased for fifty
dollars so it's a pretty simple problem
to get see if you can pause the video
and do it on your own and we'll go
through together the basic idea here
though is you've got six dollars times
the number of adult tickets we'll just
say a for adult plus four dollars times
the number of children's tickets equals
a total of fifty dollars so that's all
really it is it's the cost times the
quantity plus the cost times the
quantity equals the total and so that's
your that's your linear combination
linear just means line and you basically
got how much you're collecting for the
adult tickets plus the number the amount
collected total for the children's
tickets equals the total so linear
combinations something important
understand for the f80 go ahead and
review this lesson if you need to
otherwise i'll see you in the next
lesson